yes we saw one multiple time champ win
her game and another who's won two
titles won her game as well nazi
congratulations gotta say though at some
point in this game especially when she
played bishop h3 we're starting to think
you might be in some trouble
what a big turnaround for you
uh thank you i just want to say i'm so
happy i won it's been such a long time
since i won a classical game
um i could feel that
somewhere after bishop h3 i was
probably worse but position is so messy
and
i wanted that kind of position today
that's why i prepared the dutch i've
never played it before
so i was probably worse for a move or
two but i feel like i ended up
outplaying her
right at this moment we thought c5 would
have been problematic for you
just to create some dangerous chances
but as you said when she didn't take the
bull by the horn she started playing
a couple of slower moves and suddenly
you were able to ride the ship
so position is too complicated we both
need to make
very accurate moves and she was pretty
low on time as well so
i i was not really afraid
a very important quality to have
certainly
and then all of a sudden it was made
like
how did that happen
i calculated this line from afar
actually i was so happy it actually
happened on the board
um
yeah after i play queen g4 and bishop d4
her king has no moves the bishop cannot
move knight cannot move so i just
figured i need to move my rooks from f
file to e file so i can get closer to
her king so i don't know if she had
c takes d5 was definitely a losing move
after i played rookie seven
but i'm not sure she had
a way to equalize again
because i i like my position here a lot
maybe
if she can force some exchanges i was
looking at queen d1
right away
maybe that's the best move
but of course i'm still better right
going for it there
you drew four games before getting here
how did you feel about those four draws
how you're
doing in in the tournament before this
round
and draw is always a fine result and uh
i didn't really always not not always
good some draws
[Music]
but i never really had a
big advantage in any of the games
um so
draw was okay uh in first four games my
preparation just never worked out i
couldn't guess my opponent's openings
now you're at plus one you've joined
irina at plus one as well the leaders
aren't making any separation time to
make a run
yeah um with the two rest days it feels
like we have three different tournaments
the first half already ended and now
we're in the second half probably the
most important one
so i'm just you know taking one game in
a day all right well thanks for joining
us congratulations on your win thank you
naji i just got to ask you that you went
through this uh hiatus but you didn't
play for a few years
do you when when you return so to speak
into tournament chess and you're thrown
into
you know the competition are you feeling
rusty or is everything just coming back
and it just feels good to be back
how do you feel about that surprisingly
i don't feel that rusty even though i
didn't play even online really just
before this tournament i played the
online olympiad and that was it right
i feel like
i was hoping it uh it was like riding a
bicycle and it feels that way right okay
well welcome back it's good to have you
good to see you thank you yes absolutely